le gratin de pâtes cas car écoutez moi
vous faites toujours la même erreur
quand vous voulez faire un gratin de
pâtes qu'est ce que vous faites
répondez-moi magicien vous fait chausser
bouillir tout ça vous fait toujours
bouillir des pattes vous les égoutter et
à ce moment là vous les mettez dans un
plat vous mettez votre fromage vos
ingrédients dedans et roy vous balancer
ça au four pas tout non non nous les
pattes ça se met en gratin en direct
regarder 2 oignons on a déjà acheté le
premier regard c'est le premier roignot
oui le profil obligés tout à l'heure la
rentrée j'ai perdu la main ça reviendra
pour le stade a perdu qu'un point et
qu'est ce qui constituait regard des
victimes du travail
enfin la moitié du premier rognon comme
sony et l autre moitié encore une
humoriste repris dans s'il te plaît
nos camarades oui me met le plat qui
allume le feu ici tu poses letra dessus
et il met deux cuillères à soupe de
beurre dans ce grand plat à gratin
tu peux faire pour une quête épique et
défend les intérêts à ce que demain le
pirée à soupe de beurre de boire j'ai
mettre de l'huile mois rangement voilà
qui va se passer
le bordel ben ça c'est pas des cuillères
à soupe ça c'est pas danser des
cuillères pour bébé alors on peut plus
grâce à nous et voilà tu peux enlever
retrait on n'a plus besoin
et pendant que le beurre grésy regarder
ce que j'ai devant moi un beau poivrons
j'enlève le pédoncule on n'a pas dit que
c'était aux soucis de toulouse toulouse
c'est ta patrie autour ça a été j'ai
passé vraiment une partie de ma jeunesse
et je regretterai toujours un peu
toulouse le capitole et la place du
capitole la halle brighi enfin tout ce
qui a été ma jeunesse c'est quoi et là
maintenant ce poivrons je le coupe pas
en fines tranches
pour inciter à qui un temps d'un brésil
mais tu mets les oignons dedans s'il te
plaît et tu commences mais tout tu mets
tout les oignons et tu commences à les
faire douce non suer les oignons pas les
téléspectateurs comme moi malades avec
un toit on ne sait plus coupées on ne
sait plus rien faire mais c'est pas
grave nous allons y arriver quand même
c'est ça risque de notre métier donc le
poivron regarder ce que je fais après
les avoir coupé en fines tranches
je les coupe également en petits cubes
et nous allons ajouter ce cube de
poivrons dans les oignons pour les faire
dorer avec les oignons
tu sais ce que tu fais tu piques que les
saucisses et le foot toulouse prime avec
une fourchette
je suis de toulouse avec les gens nancy
passe actuelle
si j'étais dépité pourquoi est ce que tu
fais ça et je pique manger pourquoi si
je fais pour que l victor voilà qu'elles
n'éclatent pas à l'appui les plus que
soigneusement donc quelque chose qui me
pique que les saucissonner picoler et
regarde moi aussi j'ai fini le poivron
et moi j'ai piqué les aussies bon alors
ce poivrons maurice
je vais l'ajouter dans l'amélioration
qu'ils ont d'avoir aussi doucement ses
jolies absar ou si peu à peu fait pas
peur
j'ai quoi garde poivrons dans oignons et
tu me rappelles au fait les marques la
fa llait qualité de poivrons qui
existent ça me fera plaisir
oui mais alors tu di pou avons c'est
juste bon bah y'a quand même des
qualités de poivrons alors quelles sont
elles alors je les marque et parce que
je suis papou souvient le lie au lot le
haut que le iphone os et honni yolande
et lloris et oui c'est le carré de
cavaillon decarel cavaillon il ya le
lampion de l'emploi et puis alors un
superbe
si la soul à je voudrais seulement
timoré le h 28 17
c'est le piment enragé regarder devant
nous
300 g de champignons de paris et
champignons on les a laver soigneusement
et on a coupé la queue et on les a
coupés en cubes comme ceux ci éprouvent
ce que je dois couper en poudre on ici
c'est un champignon
alors tu vas regarde contre ans d'abord
comme ceci ensuite un tout petit cube et
pourquoi est ce qu'on les coupe en
petits cubes
parce qu'on va les retrouver après dans
l'enduit le matin de pat tu peux s'il te
plaît mettre la poêle sur ce fort
maintenant tu allumes le sport ce qui
faisait la poêle versez la sur le
fenugrec mis le feu et tu poses la poêle
2 6 et dans cette poêle qu'est-ce que tu
mets 2 cuillères à soupe d'huile
d'arachide voix rugueuse sur feu votre
association âgées géré par wifi maximum
la cuillère à soupe d'huile d'arachide
alors une cuillerée pendant ce temps je
fini de couper mes petits champignons
que je mets dans l'assiette effet je
vais venir
m les champignons
dans les oignons et les poivrons nous
n'avons toujours pas sale
un lit remarqué mais alors maintenant je
vais te remplacer une seconde qu'un
d'analysé de rien faire je suis cuit
doucement nous allons mélanger
champignons poivrons et oignons et
qu'est-ce qui se passe
un champignon contiennent une eau de
végétation il faut que cette eau de
végétation s'évapore c'est à dire que ça
va un petit peu relâché de l'eau est à
nouveau resserré tu vois ce qu'on fait
les filles ont failli cesser du
champignon de paris
et c'est reparti et beau d'ailleurs
formés couleurs et c'est à ce moment là
que ça sera prêt pour que nous
terminions le matin et en même temps
près ce que nous faisons nous mettons
dans la poêle 4 saucisse de ton expliqué
s'affairent entre 5 et 600 grammes mais
c'est un gratin pour 8 personnes et nous
allons laisser simplement dorer les
saucisses des deux côtés non pas les
faire cuire mais simplement les faire
dorer en fait il va nous falloir 2
minutes de chaque côté ce qui va nous
faire quatre minutes au total
et quatre minutes pour que les
champignons les oignons et les poivrons
finissent de bien se mélanger ce soit
aux est ensemble et on se retrouve
finalement 4e but on a toujours vendu
les parts dans quatre numéros
et regarde regarde ce qui s'est passé
maurice tu as vu des champignons c'est
l'autre oui des champions grosbill
robitaille et l'eau s'est enlevé et
maintenant on est prêt alors qu'est ce
que je fais j'enlève ma toile je vais
écouter et à leurs noms mais gouttes les
saucisses je les lis un disque dur d'un
traceur sur la planche mais cette fois
ne sert plus à rien et maintenant
qu'est-ce que nous allons serait
qu'elles ont à leur cause s'il te plaît
notre force est fait pour faire le plein
serai je force un camp d'été
on éteint sa demande et qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant a les pattes
nous allons ajouter quatre verres de
pâtes style papillon
il faut pas des pâtes creuse tu vois ce
que je veux dire car si on avait les
pattes creuse ont procuré les quantités
quatre verres se sentir heureux j'espère
qu'il n'a que faire de mes piles quatre
piles et tu me touches à 6 je plais
complètement à mélenchon tu mélanges
bien un peu plus vite quand je vais le
faire ça maintenant vivre de façon à ce
que maintenant tout tes pattes se
mélangent directement accrue dont le
plat avec quoi avec les oignons les
champignons et les neuf reines et nous
ajoutons écoutez moi bien ce que je vais
vous dire que c'est très fort ici c'est
très important
exactement la même quantité d'eau que de
pâtes quatre verres d'eau 1
3 et 4 si on fait plus de padt faut
mettre la même chose ça fait 5 verres de
son nom mais si on fait plus donc
évidemment mon ressort mais moi je le
sais je vais être maintenant le sel oui
une belle cuillère à café de sel
il est midi avec les jeux poivre et là
regardez ce que je fais et j'ajoute 50 g
de gruyère râpé
je vais mélanger baisser le feu là et
puis tout doucement
nous allons attendre l'ébullition de
l'eau pendant ce temps je vais couper
les saucisses qui sont devant de
toulouse regarde regarde comment je vais
couper en tranches
tu vois de cette épaisseur et pendant
que je couperai su ce qui est
inintéressant oui je vous rappelle les
proportions du gratin de pâtes aux
saucisses de toulouse pour un gratin de
pâtes pour huit personnes
il nous a fallu 80 de pâtes papillon 4e
revers de 20 centilitres la même
quantité d'eau c'est à dire quatre
verres d'eau de 20 cm 2 oignons 2 et 1
poivron vert qui n'existe pas oui c'est
vrai si c'est 1 97 300 g de champignons
de paris que nous avons coupé en petits
cubes 4 saucisse de toulouse
c'est à dire 500 g de saucisse de
toulouse un peu d'huile pour les
saucisses 2 cuillères à soupe de beurre
pour faire revenir les oignons le
poivron et les champignons huile
d'arachide 1 2
archi brûlé environ 200 g de fromage de
gruyère râpé et puis du sel et puis du
poivre et puis qu'est ce qui se passe
regarde mais ceux ci se sont coupés
alors j'approche mais saucisses ici
regardez vos nourrissage étals bien mes
pattes comme ceci pour que elle baigne
bien également dans l'eau qui arrive à
ébullition tu le vois et maintenant je
vais ranger de su conserver sur les
arrange dessus d'abord toutes les
tranches tu peux m'aider d'ailleurs si
tu sais pas trop où j'en ai dû me les
rangent soigneusement tu vois que chacun
puisse quand il va piquer dans ce gratin
les avoir avoir la même quantité car il
ya des gourmands qui vont dire comment
et moi maman pourquoi j'ai pas lu ma
quantité de saucisses et tout et c'est
du range des saucisses dedans comme ceci
là ça y est je prends les noirs qui est
là j'appuie légèrement sur les saucisses
pour les faire rentrer dans le tout je
monte maintenant le feu pour
l'ébullition qui est forte en est là qu
est ce que je vais faire je vais
largement saupoudrer de gruyère râpé
il ya plus d'un vannier danse c'est fini
on se plaint finalement trois semaines
ce que me disent tu me passes élégance
et puis je vais mettre les gants et tu
vois j'ai mis là quand même 100 g de
gruyère râpé de civils voilà je mets les
gants et générera élégant petit matin
qu'est ce que je fais j'ai allumer le
four qui est préchauffé thermostat 8 8 x
3 24 240 degrés je prends le plat et je
le mets au four thermostat 8 pour 20
minutes deux fois dix et vingt minutes
après il y est déjà plein essor regardez
le gratin de pâtes à la saucisse de
toulouse on dirait attention aux yeux tu
me passes dans l'assiette
merci moi ce que je le prends la regarde
mon récit regarde alors c'est un plat
économique regarde les pattes coquine
souhait et qui nécessite peu de bugs
facile à faire pour la rentrée 1 2
septembre c'est pas mal je me sers tout
de suite tu commences à goûter un ace
que je crois que le temps qui nous est
imparti est terminée alors on vous dit
au revoir merci de nous avoir écoutés à
la semaine prochaine au revoir moi et
moi un peu quand même
comment tu te
je pense
[Musique]